nous passons donc au décryptage de cette
édition bonsoir Alice 26 juin nous
évoquons la Quinzaine des entreprises
c'est à plaisir dans les ivelines
exactement la ville de plaisir qui
renouvelle ce rendez-vous assez
régulièrement qui invite à découvrir
l'envers du décor des entreprises
bonsoir à nos invités Véronique Guernon
bonsoir vous êtes délégué au Commerce à
l'Artisanat et aux entreprises à la
ville de plaisir face à vous Mathieu
fourc bonsoir vous avez participé à
plusieurs de ces visites vous allez nous
raconter un petit peu comment ça s passé
alors à Plaisir 1300 entreprises et
sociétés sont implantées l'an passé
elles étaient 12 à participer à cet
événement aujourd'hui elles sont 15 avec
des grands groupes comme Decathlon deco
ou encore ourtou et puis des entreprises
plus modestes cette opération se déroule
jusqu'au 28 juin une première question
Véronique Guernon comment est née cette
initiative alors dans le cadre de mes
activités d'élu je suis amené à
rencontrer des dirigeants des
représentant d'entreprises TPE de PME
aussi de grosses entreprises et euh où
outre le fait de les accompagner dans
leur campagne de recrutement de leur
faciliter aussi des accès à la propriété
s' lorsqu'il se développent lorsque leur
activité s'accroit je suis amené aussi à
m'intéresser à leur activité
et des dirigeants et des représentants
d'entreprise m'ont fait part de leur
passion comment est né leur le leur
entreprise donc l'initiative est venue
des entreprises et non pas des
particuliers qui pourraient par
curiosité voilà faire tout à fait c'est
né lors de nos rencontres donc il y a
des entreprises qui sont très anciennes
hein historiquement il y en a certaines
comme celle d'ourtou que je nommerai ce
soir qui est implanté à plaisir depuis
1938 38 donc donc elle fait partie du
patrimoine de plaisir comme d'autres
aussi tout aussi importantes et qui
voilà donc c'est né ainsi on voit sur
sur ces images une visite qui a eu lieu
cet après-midi justement dans une des
entreprises c'est c'est c'est important
d'insuffler ce goût pour l'entreprise le
goût de le le goût de l'entreprise de
d'organiser ses visites je je m'adresse
à vous quand quand vous visitez ces ces
entreprises qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
ça vous apporte c'est la curiosité c'est
en fait c'est c'est une certaine
curiosité de savoir comment ils sont
historiquement implantés dans la ville
et comment ils sont organisés pour être
un acteur des fois
national plus pour JC deco par exemple
un acteur national euh et ourtou qui est
implanté depuis des années aussi il a
commencé avec un seul bus et on voit
maintenant il a plus de 250 salariés
donc c'est intéressant de voir comment
euh s'ils ont des liens forts avec leurs
salariés et avec les habitants aussi en
fait l'ANT passé 300 400 personnes qui
ont suivi à peu près ces ces visites
quel est le profil ce sont des curieux
ce sont des gens qui cherchent un emploi
peut-être aussi oui alors tout à fait
tout public confondu alors 400 visiteurs
l'année dernière en septembre dernier
ont visité les entreprises euh un petit
peu moins cette année mais bon on est on
est content aussi de cette de cette
opération à peu près 350 personnes sont
venus visiter et euh voilà donc on est
tout public oui que ça soit on va dire
de 7 à plus d'âge hein sont venus
visiter les entreprises il y a aussi les
demandeurs d'emploi he demand trouv un
emploi il y a des gens qui ont trouvé un
emploi quinzain je ne sais pas peut-être
en tout cas il peut y avoir quelques
messages qui ont été lancés vers les dir
g des dirigeants aussi qui peuvent
recruter et qui peuvent lancer quelques
messages aux visiteurs alors vousur
mathieur fourc vous ne cherchez pas
d'EMP parce que vous êtes salarié est-ce
que vous avez été surpris lors de ces
visites est-ce que vous avez découvert
des choses auxquelles vous ne vous
attendiez pas ben déjà j'ai été surpris
de la présence des vra des vrais
dirigeants ils nous ont pas souvent
délégué une secrétaire une assistante
ils étaient vraiment là pour expliquer
une vraie implication ils étaient
vraiment là pour expliquer leur entprise
comment ils vivaient leur ville et leur
métier donc c'était intéressant et il y
avait comme disait madame Guernon il y
avait tout tout public donc on pouvait
aussi échanger avec des des retraités
avec des demandeurs d'emploi avec
d'autres salariés d'autres gérants
d'autres entreprises qui venaient voir
aussi un peu l'organisation donc tous
cet échang étai assez sympathique il y a
un vrai partenariat qui s'est noué avec
les entreprises et la ville il y a des
obligations aussi de participer au forum
d'emploi par exemple des choses comme ça
ce sont des partenair régulier oui vous
avez absolument raison lors de nos
actions différentes actions que nous
menons à la de plaisir dans les actions
récemment justement de la des seniors de
la mixité et d'autres action si je peux
dire que les entreprises qui nous
accompagnent sont réellement pour celles
qui ont l'habitude de nous accompagner
nos partenaires oui parce que le service
Développement économique c'est une
dizaine de personnes à la ville de
plaisir dans une ville on disait où il y
a plus de 1300 entreprises comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour séduire les
entreprises pour qu'elles restent qu'ell
s'implant sur le territoire quels sont
les services que vous proposez alors la
palette de services pour parler ainsi
c'est euh l'accompagnement leur facilité
dans la recherche dans leur dans leur
recherche dans le cadre du de leur
développement bien de les mettre en
relation avec les propriétaires qui
louent du bâti ou qui qui louent qui
vendent du bâtis ou qui louent qui
vendent euh des surfaces donc c'est une
façon d'accompagner de faciliter euh le
rapprochement propriétaire et acteurs
économique donc on les retient en effet
en en leur apportant des solutions tant
sur les surfaces que aussi de leors de
recrutement
ensuite par rapport justement aux
objectifs de de votre service c'est
aussi de trouver de l'emploi je reste
sur cette thématique là parce qu'on sait
la situation de l'emploi est toujours
tendu donc est-ce qu'on se tourne aussi
vers vous pour trouver un emploi
bénéficier des relations vous avez noué
avec ces entreprises alors le
développement économique permet d'avoir
de nourrir déjà un outil qui est
l'Observatoire l'Observatoire est un
outil et un outil de travail de de
l'équipe pour pouvoir insérer dans la
base de données la typologie des
entreprises le nom nombre les effectifs
pour chaque entreprise mais de la petite
jusqu'à la plus grosse le le nombre de
femmes le nombre d'hommes la nature
d'activités le nombre aussi
d'administratif et voilà de pouvoir les
accompagner lors du recrutement de
pouvoir aussi dérouler mettre en place
des actions qui répondrait en fonction
bien sûr du marché du travail de pouvoir
mettre en synergie les entreprises avec
les demandeurs d'emploi vous remplacez
pas pour l'emploi pour autant je non non
nous n'avons pas cette ambition ce n'est
pas du tout notre cœur de métier
seulement c'est un service parallèle
mais qui ne fait pas doublon puisque
nous nous invitons nos les personnes qui
viennent qui se présentent à la Maison
de l'Entreprise et de l'emploi viennent
d'une façon bénévoles nous les invitons
lorsqu'il y a des forums lorsqu'il y a
des rendez-vous
elles se mobilisent dans la plupart du
temps elles sont très motivées pour
rechercher de l'emploi elles viennent
ici en lors des forums en speeddating
pour pouvoir euh être recruté les
entreprises aussi dans un court lapse de
temps euh propose des des offres
d'emploi et et voilà cette synergie
cette mise en relation permet très
rapidement de pouvoir recruter ou de
trouver un emploi alors la quinzaine de
l'entreprise se termine le 28 juin donc
dans 2 jours les visites sont gratuites
sur inscription quelles sont les les
prochaines à venir avant le 28 juin
alors les prochaines alors la Cain des
entreprises pour cette Dee édition est
terminée va bientôt sminer à le 28 juin
il reste des visites ou pas rest oui oui
encore demain euh rendez-vous fin de
matinée je crois
à la boulangerie au centre commercial de
plaisir et puis ensuite nous avons
longlerorie et voilà vous allez y
participer ça fait partie des visites
que vous allez faire vous allez visiter
toutes les entreprises de plaisir non
alors justement j'ai moi j'ai visité un
peu les plus les les grosses entreprises
sit historique en étant moi-même d'une
autre entreprise pour voir comment ça
s'articulait etce que ça peut vous
servir dans votre activité aussi voilà
exactement et en fait ce qui est surtout
intéressant avec le service économique
de la ville de plaisir c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment dans le dans le concret on
n'est pas laissé dans une salle le chef
d'entreprise est vraiment là et c'était
vraiment ça qui est enfin c'est ça qui
m'a plu demain je ne peux pas participer
parce que j'ai malheureusement des
d'autres rendez-vous trava voilà faut
bien travailler mais sinon c'est vrai
que ça aurait été avec plaisir même de
voir même les plus petites entreprises
c'est toujours intéressant de voir
comment tout s'articule dans l'envers du
décor on va dire merci merci à tous les
deux d'ê ven nous parler donc de cette
opération de cette quinzaine et puis
plus de renseignements bien sûr en se
rapprochant de de vos services pour en
savoir plus sur le travail que vous
menez tout au long de l'année merci
Alice on vous retrouve demain pour un
autre décryptage dans un instant le
face- à face pour le moment Destour par
Versailles l'art contemporain est de
retour avec l'artiste portugaise Johanna
Vasconcelos elle expose 15 œuvres dont
une œuvre symbole Mariline dans la
galerie des Glaces
regardez Catherine Pégard la nouvelle
présidente du château de Versailles
l'avait affirmé lors de son investiture
les artistes exposants au château ne
viendront plus à Versailles mais pour
Versailles
Johanna Vasconcellos s'est laissé gagner
par l'atmosphère de Versailles pour
créer de nouvelles œuvres qui sont
totalement imprégné de Versailles j'ai
voulu bien sûr intégrer sans décorer et
c'est ça la difficulté c'est que dans un
espacec versaill hyper décoré il y a
plus rien à rajouter l'artiste
contemporaine notamment connu pour son
lustre géant composé de tampon
hygiénique ne verra pas cette œuvre
phare au château de Versailles Johanna
vasconellos qui succè à Jeff K ou
Takashi Murakami s'impose comme la
première femme à exposer dans ce palais
royal les chaussures avec les casseroles
avec le titre Marieline elle représente
la femme contemporaine ça veut dire la
femme au foyer plus traditionnelle la
famille la cuisine et tout ça et la
femme contemporaine qui travaille qui
fait partie de la société d'une façon
active et qui en même temps un côté
glamour l'escarpin symbole du glamour de
la femme contemporaine contraste avec
les casseroles de la maîtresse de maison
de rôles cohabitent chez la femme le
moderne de la vie quotidienne et la
tradition du foyer devis principale de
Johanna Vasconcellos utiliser les
matériaux du passé pour un discours
contemporain j'ai utilisé beaucoup de
techniques et de icônes du passé mais en
détournant dans le présent la dentelle
elle est dans les lions que ce sont les
gardes que devrai euh
prendre soin de la reine mais en même
temps ce sont des gardes qui ont perdu
leur virérilité parce qu'ils sont
habillés en dentelle quant au Homar
placé dans l'antichambre du Grand
Couvert ils évoquent directement le luxe
des repas royaux et incarnent le dauphin
et la Dauphine et que pensez de ce cœur
fait de couvert en plastique je crois
que là on a effectivement dans son œuvre
ce toujours cette
proximité de ce qui fait le quotidien
mais en même temps le luxe avec que
souvent un peu d'insolence et un peu
d'humour et en dé plaise au détracteur
l'art contemporain semble bien installé
à Versailles un lieu international
devenu au fil du temps une véritable
vitrine de l'art contemporain c'est ça
qui est important à Versailles c'est le
côté multiculturel des visitants et des
gens qui viennent du monde entier et
c'est ça qui est difficile c'est de
communiquer avec tellement de
monde c'est ainsi que s'achève notre
visite dans l'univers de Johanna
Vasconcellos pour ma part je vais
quitter versaill en l'hélicoptère et oui
on se refuse rien